thank you very much Robert
welcome everybody I'm Kamala ahmud the
economics editor of the BBC welcome
Satya to London flew in today I'm gonna
let you into a little secret as the
economics editor of the BBC and formerly
business editor of The Sunday Telegraph
I get an awful lot of books written by
chief executives and 98% of them are
abysmal and they talk in management
gobbledygook about how great they are
and all the successes they've had
usually written at the end of their
career not slap-bang in the middle
luckily Satya yours is nothing like that
it came thumping through my letterbox at
home and I sort of looked at it in a
slight degree of trepidation thinking
another one of these books that
endlessly bores on about how great the
person is but actually sakis book is
unusual can I say in that it not only
speaks to the big issues of running
global corporations of being a
technology leader in this era of such
uncertainty about where the economy
where technology where government is
going with great honesty but it also
talks with great honesty about Microsoft
itself and the mistakes the things that
need to change and why they need to
change but also it touches on the huge
issues that we're going to talk about
tonight as well as about Satya himself
as well as about Microsoft the big
issues around artificial intelligence
the growth of quantum computing the
notion of augmented reality and what do
they mean for us and the type of society
we live in
so Satya welcome kick off Hyderabad
where you were born to only the third
chief executive Microsoft has ever had
just take take it's a little bit through
that journey
well what's well thank you so much for
having me yeah
um you know growing up in Indiana's I
reflected and wrote even in this book I
don't think I had this idea that one day
I was going to make it to Redmond
Washington and then become CEO Microsoft
Oh although I'm definitely a product of
American technology in particular even
micro in fact British in American
technology because my first computer
that I my father bought for me was a
Sinclair z80 and that's where I learned
to program a bit in basic and after that
the IBM PC with DOS and
Microsoft basic had a huge influence
although even when I was learning to
code let's say I was more into cricket I
was born to two parents my father was a
civil servant with Marxist leanings and
my mother was a Sanskrit professor and
so they hardly could agree on anything
which meant that I could do whatever and
the only thing they agreed was I was
wasting my time playing cricket but I
enjoyed it and if you had asked me even
as late as even perhaps my 12th grade
and said what was your what is your
dream I would have said you know play
first-class cricket for Hyderabad and
you know play you know work for a bank
and that would be wonderful and somehow
I think my father got the idea that
that's very provincial and he forced the
hand and said you got to go out get out
of this place and I was it a place where
you could succeed because now in India
there may be not as many push factors
given the great technological revolution
that that country is and has experienced
would there be the same push factors now
as there were when you were young that's
a great question I mean I in some sense
I have you know ever since I was 21 I've
been in the United States but clearly
what's happening whether it's in India
or even in other parts of
world the idea that they can create
digital technology in the country itself
and the jobs associated with it
I think are absolutely happening I think
the circumstances of what was possible
when I was growing up were since what is
now India's reality is two very
different things but to sort of finish
up I think the thing that at least I
picked up in the school I went to and
the Malou I grew up in was some strange
combination of having intellectual
ambition and the ability to take the
moment the opportunity you're given and
make the most of it and those are the
two things then when I look back
perhaps shaped who I was who I am and
what happened you talk in the book about
a number of people who were colleagues
who also came from India this sort of
Indian diaspora who went to the United
States in particular and have been
tremendously successful would you put
that down to that that's sort of that
that march of people into America and
the success you you have there I mean I
think you know that I'm not deeply
studied the Diaspora and especially into
the United States but they seem to be at
least from what I can understand two
different faces there was a face early
on when the American immigration policy
allowed for skilled immigration which
led to I think a lot of doctors in
particular showing up and then I think I
definitely was the beneficiary of the
same immigration policy but being
applied to the growth in digital
technology especially in the early 90s I
think is when a lot of us were able to
come participate and contribute and
that's deaf I mean that's why I think
I'm such a product of the United States
I always attributed to these two
amazingly unique things American one is
its technology reaching everywhere and
allowing kids like me anywhere to dream
the dream and then the enlighten
American immigration policy that even
gave me the chance to live the dream and
so I think that that's a pretty unique
American competitive advantage your
Sinclair didn't encourage you to come to
London and meet Clive Sinclair maybe by
one of his trikes you know maybe a four
opportunity at Harvard somehow I've
never been to rest of Bombay and I
decided to show up in Milwaukee see you
join Microsoft in in 1992 raised through
the business relatively rapidly but
you're sort of a dyed-in-the-wool
Microsoft person you right at the
beginning of the book that when you took
over at Microsoft three-and-a-half years
ago that this was a company where
innovation had been replaced by
bureaucracy where teamwork had been
replaced by internal politics but you
were the consummate insider so what I
was wondering as I was reading it want
you to blame slightly for those facts
that's a great observation because in
slightly rude I don't know but I think
it's it's it's absolutely right because
I I grew up in Microsoft I've spent 25
years of my life there and everything
that is good and everything that is
wrong I was part of it and if anything
what I tried to do was not to go look
back and say let us change but it is to
rediscover after all here we are 43
years after being founded you know
competing with a whole set of new
players and it wouldn't have happened if
we would have not gotten a lot of things
right but it's also important to
acknowledge what didn't we get right
amplify the things that really help us
be at our best and then get rid of the
things that are obstacles so that was
the spirit with which at least I started
in fact even steven
best advice was he don't try to fill my
shoes or don't be victim to my own Dogma
be your own person and somehow you know
as part of even though I grew up at
Microsoft in all of the jobs I had and I
seeked out that outside in perspective
as best as a consummate inside a cat
right you know you can't be completely
objective about it and there was enough
of a debate even you know who should be
CEO Microsoft should an Insider ever be
picked given what was at least being
written now about us but in my case I I
had a pretty first-class view of what it
is that we who we are what we should do
what should we make sure we get rid of
as even cultural traits or what have you
that were obstacles and I think in
retrospect that is what was helpful to
your point an insider and there who has
some credibility perhaps being critical
of the past knowing that I'm not
criticizing myself is what makes it even
possible to change so you have to trust
of the people because you've been there
and you know maybe why some of these
things have grown up and also that
ability to say I made the mistakes so
instead of I coming down and saying or
let me tell you the mistakes you all
made let us all so it is more me as part
of the team worse as being someone from
the outside the team you talking in some
detail you go back to on a number of
occasions some of the as you say the
mistakes that Microsoft made or some of
the things which became problematic and
I was particularly interested in
Minecraft and Mojang and also in Nokia
um what is it about an organization
where it seems difficult to seize the
opportunity that with hindsight seems
sort of blindingly obvious and Minecraft
given that you did eventually buy you
could have bought it a lot earlier a lot
cheaper than when you did actually do
the deal why is it when a company can't
see what an opportunity is and grab it
you know one of the things at least I
observed which I write about as the
after at least that I think all systems
have and in particular in business this
is super important to recognize is this
amazing what you a cycle that one gets
into when one has the first success
after all when you're a startup you have
nothing but then you scale up you have
your hit around that concept or that hit
you build all the capability and then
around that capability the culture also
develops so you have this amazing lock
between your concept your capability and
your culture and they reinforce each
other and it keeps growing except there
is no such thing as a perpetual motion
machine at some point whatever you
started growing or whatever was the hit
stops being one and now the times come
for you to come up with the next hit in
order to do that you need new capability
whatever capability you may have had in
the past may not be enough
sometimes line extensions are easy but
you line extensions are not all growth
culture will then fight that so that is
what I think we need to recognize that
the PC was that where the lock he came
democratizing the PC was was Bill
Gates's great statements of the world
and did that become the lock for your
business but if you look at it one of
the things that we were able to do at
Microsoft and it's in fact even true
today about our business is we are much
more diversified in some sense you know
you can say we caught three or four big
ones and we missed a few big ones so
think about it the PC obviously but you
know even let's even say office was the
first big hit in fact them Microsoft
Office and most Word Excel were all
built for the Macintosh before even
Windows was a success then we had
Windows in office then when I joined for
example in 1992 no one thought we will
ever have a server business after all
what does a PC company have anything to
do with service that was the
conventional wisdom and then we went
after it and avi obviously became big in
service and now we have a cloud business
in parallel we even built a gaming
business with Xbox so we
done multiple things but did we miss the
web big one did we miss search even I've
heard a lot you know did we miss search
those are all big misses and mobile is
another one so but at that same time I
think that's the perspective one needs
to have as I always say you know you can
aspire to be Don Bradman but having an
about 50 average is not a bad idea for a
good test carrier so I think that
companies really do need to think about
hey don't do the missus but be more
cognizant of what in really enable
Microsoft to have four major hits how
many businesses have these 10 billion
plus franchises ok so let's tell us
hacia what are what are the keys to the
big hits we'll get we'll get back to the
misses in a second but let's let's hear
about the hits first and it's it's not
about a growth mindset is based pop one
of you things in your book it's a great
point which is in some sense one of the
things that I said well what's the mean
we can have where this culture that we
have today doesn't inhibit us to go
after a new concept or building of new
capability and that is where I mean I my
wife had actually introduced me to this
book by Carol Dweck called mindset you
know a few years before I had become CEO
and I was reading it more in the context
of my daughter's and that book talks
about this very simple metaphor that
it's better to be a learn at all versus
a know-it-all and I think large
successful companies tend to culturally
become know-it-alls because after all
you're successful you must know
something except if you don't have that
learn at all posture you're not going to
be open so that's where the concept of
growth mindset comes from and we've
adopted it internally at least as a meme
because the last thing when I want what
our last thing I want to do about
culture was to say you know here are the
cultural attributes ABC let's replace
them with X Y Z because that's not
enduring if anything you know people
will forget XYZ as fast
they never thought about ABC so to me it
needed to be something that had even
breathing space so everyone more
confronted their fixed mindset sometimes
in Microsoft you know people will come
to me and say South you found the five
people who don't have a growth mindset
and like I always say well that's I mean
obviously that's not the point for you
to confront starting with me my fixed
mindset then God knows I make a lot of
mistakes every day and am I willing to
admit am I willing to be vulnerable
enough and that I think is that poor
culture that is needed for innovation
and to me there is it's not a formula
that's why I think it's more of a
mindset
I could imagine working for Bill Gates
or Steve Ballmer sort of vulnerability
might not be something you really want
to show in in a sort of office meeting
as Steve Ballmer's wanting to know why
you haven't hit your targets that month
I mean it's quite hard isn't it for
people to to really feel that they can
say oh do you know what's that here I've
slightly screwed up here actually I mean
one of the things I've learned look bill
and Steve are guys who have perhaps the
most intellectual honesty in anybody I
have met they the thing that they're
always pushing on is to make sure that
you're not feeding them BS and so in
some sense I felt that the easiest thing
to do with them is to just be very
factual knowing that their standards are
so high that even the highest of
achievements is not going to measure up
you special
you spoke about um you speak a lot in
the book about culture and you talk
about empathy and this is a world where
there's a lot of cynicism about business
you're talking about empathy not just
internally but particularly externally
and particular with your customers in
the main you talk about but I was quite
interested in that idea of empathy and
empathetic approach given that the lots
of people are suspicious the businesses
aren't
empathetic at all they're just about
their investors in the bottom line and
making as much profit as possible it's a
little bit about this approach and why
you use this word empathy so regularly
you know to mean one of the things I
look back and say when did we create our
best products and these hits beyond
having a culture which was let's say
more the learn at all culture I think
the thing that we also had was a deep
sense for what are the unmet
unarticulated needs of customers because
if you said ok I'm gonna talk to five
people and sort of do what they tell me
to do that's definitely not going to
really get you to a hit product now you
have to have a deeper intuition where
does that come from I believe the best
source of it is empathy when you are
observing the world when you're talking
to customers when you are seeing things
happen if you are truly listening not
just to the words but sort of what's
behind them that's the inspiration for
innovation and so it's an existential
business need then the question is how
does one develop it I can go to work and
say oh I'm gonna be empathetic because
that's just you know it's it's it's
impossible to just switch it on if you
don't have essentially the learning from
your own life's experience that's one of
the things I sort of even perhaps more
so thought through in this book why do I
talk like this or why did it read this
come from at least in my case and then
I realized that it all came from these
hard lessons whether it was that first
interview question or the last interview
question that I got in my Microsoft you
know after eight hours of you know
solving these math puzzles and computer
science algorithms by the interviewer
asked me what will you do if you see a
baby who's fallen on the street and I
thought oh my god this is an algorithm I
didn't learn there must be some puzzle
here I've got to solve and I'd searched
for a couple of minutes and then I said
i'll call 9-1-1 the interviewer just
gets up and he walks out and shows me
you know sends me on my way and he says
you know when a baby falls you picked
him up and hugged them and that you know
i taught so much I thought I blew it and
I'll never get the job but you know
eventually I did but that's the kind of
experience or whether it's the birth of
my son which is another very big turning
point for us those are the moments that
in some sense grounded me but having had
those personal experiences I think they
informed who I was as a leader or a
manager as an engineer and that's the
connection at least I see I want to pick
up on the engineer point in a minute but
I do want to ask you about you you talk
very movingly about Zayn
your wife Anu and Zayn your son who has
special needs I was born very
prematurely how what did you take from
that which which it allowed you to as
you say you can't switch empathy on but
what was it about that experience that
changed maybe the way you view not just
your personal life but also your work
life yeah I mean for you and me arm he
was a first child
both of us were their only children of
our parents and if you even had asked me
an hour before he was born
what does top of mind for me it was all
about A's and nursery got to be ready is
on we're going to get back to a job as
an architect what a lot of weekends be
like in all of engineer maybe still
that's right and
I was then obviously everything changed
he was born with severe brain damage
which led to cerebral palsy and then I
watched I know pick up you know in fact
right after she came out she had a
c-section as soon as she could recover
as quickly as possible she was driving
him to therapy after therapy and
everything that came so naturally to her
as to what she needed to do to give Zayn
the best chance didn't come to me I was
more thinking about what happened to me
what happened to my plans why did this
happen and I must say it took me maybe
even two years or more to truly
internalize that nothing actually
happened to me something happened to
Zayn and I had to step up and see the
world through his eyes and do my job as
his father and I now understand that I
don't think the process was that linear
it was tumultuous but it definitely
shaped Who I am it perhaps gave me a
better sense of being able to see things
through other's eyes whether it's people
who work with you as colleagues or
people whom you're leading or even
customers and in a very subtle way I
think it defined it was perhaps the hit
refresh moment in my life do you think
that there is a broader issue clearly
you went through an incredibly credible
emotional journey I've been fortunate
enough to interview lots of heads of
technology companies there's big global
companies of which you now run one um
it's the problem sometimes with trying
to connect with the human world out
there that it is run by engineers who
maybe lack that journey that you've been
through which has maybe opened yourself
up to a different approach
that's you can sometimes have an issue
that you are run by engineers who find
it hard to connect with the concerns of
the outside world that we're going to
start going onto those in a little while
about AI and suchlike I mean I hope not
but I do believe to your core of your
question that in a world will talk more
I'm sure about this in a world where
there is let's say abundance of
artificial intelligence what's going to
be scarce is real intelligence or human
intelligence and human qualities like
empathy that all of us need ha it's not
going to be like I can do a Fourier
transform very fast is probably going to
be a commodity what may not be a
commodity is the ability to relate to
people and whether you're an engineer I
think great innovation quite frankly as
an engineer comes because of your real
empathy you have for the problems you
want to solve for people after all but I
would subscribe to that point of view
that let us even in how we talk about
the need for new skills don't do it in
such a way that it's so narrow that we
lose I think what makes us unique is
humans in our ability in particular to
relate to each other what did you find
was the biggest challenge starting at
Microsoft as chief executive in a
company that you had not been chief
executive for such a long time I was
wondering what the moat the main
challenge was for you you know one of
the things which is very different and
not realized this is and in fact Steve
had never even referenced this and this
is Ballmer had references and I never
really got it before he left as a CEO
you can be a CEO of a small company or a
large company the one thing that the CEO
does see is very unique because
structurally you see everything left to
right what's happening in your
organization no one who works on your
team sees it that way you see it because
they all have by definition their job to
do which is there's a structure around
it and the people you work for in our
case our board also don't see it so
there is always this asymmetry but in
some sense you've got to get your
judgment right based on what you see so
that's one I would say there's nothing
that prepares you for it
of seeing the whole picture certainly
yeah and being the one who has to pass
judgment knowing that people who are
going to judge you whether it's your
people who work for you or your board
are not seeing the same thing it's sort
of a pretty unique you know information
asymmetry challenge and then the second
thing is the multi constituent nature
right if you ask me even before I became
CEO I rattled off the classic there's
customers their shareholders
there's employees and so on but it turns
out of course you have all of those
constituents but you have governments
and you have other nonprofit
organizations all of them together
simultaneously and you've got to
harmonize those interests because your
meetings with the President of the
United States to get to yeah yeah I mean
you know government's all over we're a
multinational company operating in 190
countries in every country whether it's
in the US or in the UK it's about you
know their country first unless and
until we can show up and talk credibly
on how we are participating in creating
local opportunity whether it's their
small business productivity or their
public sector efficiency or their own
multinationals becoming competitive
because of what you do you know it's for
them it doesn't matter who you are or
what you do unless and until you're
really delivering on things that matter
to them what did you learn from the fad
as you write about in the book that
Microsoft was left standing on cloud by
Amazon what do you learn from that it's
one of those things I write quite a bit
in the book about it's a classic case
perhaps of what even you know people
will say is the challenge of that lock
between your capability concept and
culture we had a very successful data
center business in fact it was growing
even as latest in fact it still
continues to grow double-digit so why
would you say oh you know what we have a
good idea which is let's get into a very
low margin business as the next big idea
usually that's not considered good
business decision-making but yet you
sometimes have to make that when you
know that the margin structure that you
may have fall in love with is not
long-term sustainable secular changes
are going to get to a place where it's
better to increase the total pie because
what the cloud does is it's red market
expansive we aldo had a big business we
participated in a very small part of
what was the IT spend we had high
margins and we continued to have good
margins there but we needed to see
through a different lens and Amazon I
think caught on to it because they
didn't have legacy that was new for them
but you know the good news of that story
is we caught it we caught our own
mistakes in fact Steve was the one who
saw it in he got me into this role he
asked me to go aggressively gave me the
support and now it's a the fastest
growing business and quite frankly we're
doing super well in the cloud let's talk
about some of those bigger not just to
Microsoft but those bigger challenges
that technology world is facing at the
moment let's start with artificial
intelligence and where that might be
going and what I what I've described in
the past is sort of role of voice who
controls the pathway that we take you
write in the book that there's sort of a
distinction between dystopian view of
where we're gonna go and a utopian view
and actually we're going to be somewhere
in the middle how is it that the public
can trust that technology firms like
yourselves like Google like Facebook
like Amazon are going to give the public
what they need and are not going to give
the public simply what makes you money
I mean one of the things I think a lot
about is with any new technology we as a
society have to be clear-eyed on both
sides of it which is the opportunities
for this new technology to have profound
impact in our daily life and do good and
at the same time be very mindful of
unintended consequences and in fact you
know you say when the Telegraph first
came about there was wire fraud so in
other words we have seen this before
where even though technology brings a
lot of good you also have to be ready to
deal in fact using technology the
unintended consequences and I think
that's going to be true even in the case
of AI where at least I am focused on is
all of the practical things that one can
do as creators of AI for example I
believe it's actually a design choice
before we even get into the long term
morality because I do believe a lot in
path dependence right with the fact that
where you get started and how you get
started has real consequences you know
on where you end up what if we said
we're gonna create AI that empowers
humans as a core conscious design
decision I'll give you an example of it
at Microsoft one of the things that is
really great to see in fact inspired by
even some of the projects we've done in
the UK and some of the researchers in
the UK and our engineers here if we
built an app called CAI which is
available actually on the Apple App
Store uses our cloud computer vision
technology to give anyone with visual
impairment the ability to see on another
colleague of mine Angela Mills whom I
recently ran into was recounting this
she has some visual impairment as to
what it's done for her where she now can
walk into our cafeterias order food with
confidence because this app allows us to
see she can walk into conference rooms
knowing that that's the right conference
room without barging into something that
she's not been invited to and me in a
sense participating in Microsoft fully
so I believe we've got to grab onto
those opportunities now having said that
we do have to think through will we ever
get to a stage in AI development where
we have some of these runaway
optimizations which are all focused on
essentially some optimization formula
that doesn't care about humans and
that's where these you know Asimov wrote
about how to continue to solve for the
control problem we do need the moral
equivalent of that and I think we have
dealt with these even in tech how do we
fight spam or how do we fight botnets
how does the industry come together to
set standards for what are how is really
sets those standards this is the key
point I think it's it's who sets those
standards and how do you ensure that the
public and governments are involved in
that debate I know that a lot of
technology companies are thinking very
deeply about this bus and I've asked
this question of Mark Zuckerberg and
I've asked this question of sundar
pichai you can't be the only ones in
this debate because then you are setting
the parameters that some people may have
the suspicions are set for the good of
you not for the good of society whatever
you talk about how great you are and how
good you're gonna be for human beings
what's your duty to involve the rest of
the public square in this debate no for
sure so the way I look at it is first
what we need to do which we have done as
I said in lots of other areas even in
tech around setting standards you know
you do this in gaming what what in fact
there's a partnership of a I read all of
us participate in one of the
state-of-the-art
issues that we have with AI especially
with these deep neural nets is how do
they make decisions right one of the
design principles are right about we on
empowerment being one is we need to take
accountability for the AI we create we
can't abdicate
saying look this is a self learning
algorithm we don't know what it's doing
that's just not possible
I think the pub you know the society
he's not gonna accept that so that means
we need to make AI that's more
intelligible so that then we can inspect
it and then understand it that I think
is still an unsolved problem but there
are people pushing on the research of it
let us share that first of all in public
domain it's staying quite hard for
Microsoft's that's not being Microsoft's
culture in the past that open-source
approached the notion of sharing being
very collegiate your approach has been
in the past aggressive you're defined
you're trying to find those those killer
applications scale beats the opposition
there's a lot of AG look it's competing
hard and yet doing things that are in
the larger interests of the industry we
participate in and recognizing that
ultimately if all we do is seek Reince
in the short term you're not going to
have any profit in the long run right
that's I think that's what you
capitalism does teach that and so I'm
much more like in fact these lessons of
partnership even are things I learned at
Microsoft I joined my first job in the
company was to say let's recruit
third-party developers so that they can
use our server software so in fact most
people don't recognize this but we are
probably one of the biggest committers
or open-source committers to hadoop when
to Linux dotnet and everything else that
we do is now open source so I feel that
bridge has been crossed there are some
old tapes and I'm sure those little guys
you've almost been through the antitrust
battles you think you'll not be grown up
in the room Arnie maybe for the googles
and the apples and the Facebook's you've
been around for years you've been
through the battles with the
government's what lessons can we learn
from that
the place where we were going is I think
what all of us have the responsibility
to do which is if you say look there's
such a thing called good AI let us make
sure that we as an industry that is
creating these AI are setting the
standards for what that is ultimately
you're right even
it is going to be of interest to
governments all over as to what because
of the public and to the public and I
think the involvement that debate and
I'm all for it because the more we can
have more scrutiny of how this is being
created I'm not talking about regulation
because most people talk about
regulation it's hard for something like
look we are not even yet there to have a
framework of law to connect to how does
one do you know really arbitrate between
national security and privacy right
that's not even being discussed in the
ways it needs to be discussed so before
we get to AI let's solve even more
pressing challenges around cyber one of
the things that we call for for example
is the digital you know our digital
Geneva Convention
when nation-states are involved it's
fairly ridiculous for civilian
infrastructure and civilian data to be
impacted anywhere in the world and so
therefore let us in fact have that and
let us get to a place where we do our
best legislative work best diplomacy
best whatever to get to an equilibrium
in a digital world and that maybe in
fact will set precedent for how we can
even think about AI just for I come to
the audience a couple of final questions
let's talk about inequality that's one
of the big issues that technology is
facing and I don't mean particularly how
technology companies can increase
productivity can maybe tackle some of
the economic growth problems we have in
the country cuz I feel I wouldn't know
what your answer to that is what I'm
actually more interested in is the the
complaint that actually technology
companies themselves have created huge
inequalities by the fact you work in
such profitable ways and that money that
you have made has been reinvested in the
company itself and to your investors it
must make you uncomfortable that Silicon
Valley workers going to work on their
buses are being egged by local residents
who say you jacked up all the house
prices and I can't live here anymore
I mean that must be a challenge for you
it's almost
it's almost a challenge of your approach
to show that you are creating value for
people because at the moment they may be
looking at you and thinking but you're
just creating value for yourselves
look here's at least where I think it's
important are to distinguish even all of
us has separate entities and with
different business models in our case
it's existential for us for there to be
success outside of our balance sheet and
income statement he's simple because
there is no such thing we're not some
middleman in some two-sided market our
entire thing is very straightforward if
there is value in what we create you pay
us you will only pay us if you yourself
are making money whether it's a student
whether it's a public sector
organization whether it's a large
multinational our entire business model
is empowering people in organizations
and their ability to create more
technology in fact if anything that's
what gives me the greatest confidence in
our business model being able to create
more surplus outside of us because it's
in our interest it's not I'm not saying
this that we're doing this out of
altruism but our business model itself
is virtuous in the sense and take the UK
for example in fact I was just studying
this ah the nut beach started in an
apprenticeship program in collaboration
with the partner channel and something
like 10,000 apprenticeships were created
even in the last couple of years and we
plan to grow that to 30,000 and I was
thinking wow how is that happening it's
happening because these partners are
growing their own businesses in
technology around our platforms serving
customers who are using digital
technology to make their own surplus and
creating employment I believe that's
what creates long term business and
these inequities in societies I think
are a challenge because if all that
happens is one sector of the economy is
doing super well and then the rest of
the economy there is no wage growth or
there's no job growth I think it's not a
stable equilibrium user working now
I mean you even know her Ari's been on
this stage I've interviewed him wrote
Amadeus about the future of Technology
one big point he makes in that book is
the digital divide this notion that
those people who can afford the digital
act accoutrements that increase their
intelligence their reach their ability
to use AI in the most powerful way
possible will become almost these
superhuman beings and will leave almost
a sort of London proletariat behind who
simply cannot afford to engage and is a
similar argument made by now folks in
his new book the square the tower and
the square which is that the networked
people the top will create value for
themselves and we'll go on and we'll
leave this group behind if you have how
is you is the head of one of the biggest
global businesses here tackle and think
about that that's a it's up it's a great
issue of our times I think I actually
come out at the other way around
I look at it and say how do we
democratize these networks how do we are
democratize these digital platforms so
that in fact they're creating more
inclusion I mean I'll give you a great
example
you know you know the country I was born
and when I go back to India now and I
see some of the startups and their need
for capital to go after whatever it is
that they're going after has now come
down by a huge amount because they can
just use a cloud in fact one of the most
fascinating things is we all talk about
AI in fact I look at it and say the rate
at which AI is being commoditized is
faster than any other technology I've
seen in fact most of the AI research
take computer vision come for anything
he's all been done in the public domain
they were all in research papers that
are everywhere and there and people like
us have now just made that available as
commodity services in the clouds for
others to use so to some degree I feel
that we can
in in some sense create more of an equal
playing field even on the network side
LinkedIn to me what's our goal with
LinkedIn our goal with LinkedIn at the
highest of levels is to take whatever
the 3.3 billion people in the workforce
and digitize those jobs the skills the
training so that it's available as a
blueprint as it evolves not as a static
thing but as it evolves for people to
know what jobs to aspire to what skills
to acquire and where to get that
learning because I think that's going to
be very very key for economic growth and
especially of getting your own economic
return in in the City of London and I
was again pretty pleased to see that I
believe the taxpayers of this city said
you know we're gonna put aside 7 billion
now 7 million pounds and do a digital
skills initiative and it was great to
see that they took actually the LinkedIn
data around the jobs the skills and said
let's use this taxpayer dollar in a
smart way to get people to get skilled
in the jobs of the future
those are some of the mechanisms where
networks platforms and commoditization
or democratization can bring about more
broad spread economic growth as opposed
to a very narrow return now I couldn't I
can get your research before I ask you a
final question if you just explain
Donald Trump to us
you know I've met the president of
United States twice once before he was
inaugurated and once after along with a
lot of my industry colleagues a
discussion on immigration I went through
essentially what I talked about you know
I'm a product and a recipient of a
benefits of the American immigration
system why why I believe it's to our
competitive advantage to make sure that
we are smart about how we do that and
also show humanity because one of the
other things with daca in particular in
the u.s. I feel that the American ethos
is captured in not only making sure that
the best and the brightest come to the
country and skilled immigration but it's
also the being the beacon of hope for
those who needed the most and I think we
should preserve it and we are clear I'm
clear and the president obviously
listened to that and the other piece I
would also say is we talked about
investment in digital technology and
infrastructure which is much needed it's
no different quite frankly then the
conversation we had with the previous
administrations or with any heads of
state whether here or in Germany and so
that's all I have to say
very delicately handled there's asking
question there's a man right in the back
who's urgently pretty signed up they
will have them that's a number two there
there's a judge Bell up number two first
and then there's a very fast man up
there number four yeah number four great
in the white shirt hello hi thank you
very much for a very interesting
conversation my question is regarding
artificial intelligence and you
mentioned how fast is being commoditized
and my question is how how do you think
how scared we should be as humans of
artificial intelligence replacing our
everyday jobs especially considering the
fact that a lot of humans derive their
self-identity from from the jobs that we
do every day thank you so here's how I
would think about this one is clearly as
there's more automation because of AI
there's going to be very hard
displacement now I think what do we need
to do in order to prepare for that is
first actually let's actually grab on to
every job opportunity there is where we
can race with the machine there's a lot
been written about that sometimes we
sort of go all the way to full
automation where the job is gone except
it's not like in fact I'll give you an
another example of our interesting
collaboration in radiology
between Cambridge and University of
Washington and Microsoft are where
they're using artificial intelligence to
go through all of the images with in
preparation for radiotherapy
because one of the more tedious process
while you're preparing is to go through
and make sure that you're not going to
get you're just gonna get the tumor but
not the other rest of the organs and
that process sometimes can be
error-prone and also takes a lot
so let's empower the radiologists with
the latest assistive AI technology so
that they can one get their job done
faster and spend more time with the
patient
sometimes we go all the way let's say
all the radiologists are going to be
displaced and it's not going to happen
in that sequence having said that let's
say let's take it to a next step if
there is full automation in any job let
us not fall victim to this thinking that
there is a lump of Labor you know
economists call it the lump of Labor
fallacy and now question is are all the
jobs that are going to be there in the
future that have already been created
obviously not and that's where something
like this linked in economic graph can
even act as a real-time feedback signal
so instead of trying to speculate about
what the future is let us again shape
our skills and our economy with the
real-time signal for example I'm a big
believer that people on people jobs are
going to be huge in our economies they
need to be supported through policy with
wages and so as things let's say the
capital is be you know is getting a huge
return because of automation but labor
is required somewhere else we will need
to come up with mechanisms of the return
on capital and return on labor with the
right equation so I think there are many
things we can do in terms of how to in a
clear-eyed sense look at AI it's
progress the market signal and policy so
that we can be prepared versus thinking
it's going to be dystopian as a binary
state transition number for the back
thank you very much for an absolutely
fascinating talk can I please get a link
to the first question your comment on
online education I think particularly
over the next considerable number of
decades the new jobs are coming into
existence are going to demand a very
specific skill set and the old model
where you would go to university get a
Bachelor of Arts in any subject that's
completely obsolete its obsolete now
know the tuition fees are far too high
the actual and what you actually learn
is not demanded anymore
do you see online education things like
harvardx online where you could do learn
Excel you can learn accounting you put
on earth resume and then you could
provide to an employer for a fraction of
the cost and do you see online education
of
acting secondary and primary education
as well not just in tertiary level I
mean in all honestly I'm not the deepest
of experts to speculate on that
trajectory ah I observe it I observe it
in primarily through what we are trying
to get done in LinkedIn because we're
trying to address that very challenge
which is the requirement of skills or
the mapping of skills to jobs is very
dynamic and it's changing and therefore
it's super important for us to really
have learning that relates to those
skills required for the jobs that's what
we describe as the economic graph and so
that's why we're pouring a lot into the
learning aspect LinkedIn got started
obviously more by trying to just map the
jobs and the skills but we recognize
that learning is I think going to be
super important especially people aspire
for returns on their labor and their
Economic Opportunity now having said
that what's the best mechanism I think
we should tackle some of the challenges
you brought out which is the high cost
of education more head-on before we say
the educational system is itself
irrelevant maybe if we said let's figure
out a way for it to be more accessible
and then also recognize that just going
to college and graduating is good enough
to be insuring yourself of all of your
future economic opportunity I think it's
just not gonna be true anymore I think
you have to go rescale so these
apprenticeship programs in job training
programs for example or at Microsoft and
I look at all of what we are trying to
do even for engineers when something a
new technology like AI comes in we are
doing AI schools you have to in some
sense hit the books again in a massive
way but in an applied sense and so those
are I think what is the responsibility
of individuals
but they need assistance of tools and
networks definitely LinkedIn is one of
them but also businesses and business
leaders who are willing to invest in the
training of their people so I think
that's at least what I would say is what
needs to happen and we see I mean the
MOOCs definitely have a role to play
you know I sign up for more MOOCs than I
finish but it's it's the fact that you
can accept you know access them it's
just fantastic down here number one yeah
due to just how many companies are
seizing the opportunity of the digital
revolution would you say that the next
Microsoft or Apple is a realistic
possibility in the new future you know
every time anyone has sort of said the
success that anyone has had can't be
surpassed all you have to do is wait a
little and they have been surpassed so I
do believe that innovation will come
companies will get built success will
happen but it may not happen even
narrowly like we think of it today as
what is high-tech one of the most
fascinating things that I'm observing as
part of what I see around the world is
every company I work with whether it's
rolls-royce or whether it is BMW or
anyone they're digital companies today
in other words they have to in fact
build their own software capability to
produce these smart things the smart
cities the smart financial products so I
don't think it's not going to be the
case that there's going to be a high
tech industry or a digital industry and
then the rest I think we're all it's
like electricity I think we're all going
to have the ability to use this new
essential factor of production in very
innovative ways and if anything one of
the things I write about in the book is
the need of the are both in terms of
entrepreneurial
energy and return quite frankly is that
some of the harder challenges like
climate change or any of the other in
food production even are being solved by
our entrepreneurs who get the backing of
risk capital and then obviously the
return so that there's more investment
in sectors of the economy that go very
beyond even an arrow let's say consumer
led Internet
yep number three I'd like to return to a
cricket theme if possible do you think
the V drift to twenty20 cricket away
from Test cricket is symptomatic of a
generational shift to instant graphic
gratification maybe a be expensive depth
and substance you know let me say I
wholeheartedly agree with you I'm gonna
go to the Lord's tomorrow it's about the
very very first time ever ever stepped
in there I I admire and I love watching
Test cricket unfortunately I don't have
the time for it but luckily it off
because of at least streaming media you
can watch it in small chunks all over
and I able to me that's the only form of
cricket that I enjoy you you talk in
your book about this need for this big
thought process around AI but picking up
on the gentleman's point no one's gonna
bother about that
they'll want whatever it is as quickly
as possible and you you will need to
give it to them you're gonna be able to
sit around there you know Socrates like
you know thinking about well where are
things going because your competitors
are gonna be out there moving faster
moving fast and breaking things
it's a graceful I always be technologies
work it's a great point but let me just
sort of argue a couple of things which
is this is I guess somebody was saying
there's a debate between the 1984 and
the brave new world and that's a
fantastic debate to be had because in
some sense what's what's probably as
much of a challenge is the brave new
world and that is our own ability
to amuse ourselves to death is a
challenge if it's not checked
I'll give you where I get my inspiration
for this minecraft when I watch the
Minecraft generation they are not just
playing a game they are taking what is
their imagination and bringing it to
life in fact one of the interesting data
points is if you introduce minecraft in
education it equalizes even on the
gender side the approach to stem in fact
it brings more girls because they're not
again
bound to some particular curriculum of
computer science that may even have a
bias so I think the more creation tools
we put in place people will choose for
even this instant gratification by doing
things that are much more digital but
artisanal like one of the other
fascinating things I've been watching is
paint Microsoft Paint is used by a
hundred million people every month you
know I was like wow that's pretty
stunning so we said what are they doing
in fact
they're doodling they're painting in
fact we have this other property called
miksa where people watch game streaming
but it's not just game streaming they're
watching people code they're watching
people paint and so we then said let's
take inspiration from that and build
even this 3d paint and so now in Windows
we have 3d paint so that that's in fact
the atomic particle for this virtual
reality or mixed reality world because
after all if you're gonna have Holograms
you need artists of the new form who
create these artifacts so I think we've
got to start redefining even how people
get satisfaction what is entertainment
what is the creation versus consumption
the equation sometimes is let me get
quick consumption hits that I think is
not the be-all end-all of what satisfies
us deeply as humans yeah number one
number one and then we'll come into this
block here is the gentleman there at the
time a question about you what if
anything did you learn from your Marxist
father
[Applause]
I would say the one thing that I did
learn was I mean think about what an
audacious guy Marx was in having the
intellectual ambition to essentially put
a formula to history and my father
definitely had that he was a person who
is a person who loves ideas and pushes
new ideas and he instilled that love for
ideas in me but if I think about even
some of the issues we talked about
around equity or the raise rise of
inequity we do need in our social
democracies or our capitalist societies
deal with some of the dystopian views
that Marx had of late-stage capitals
I think rereading that is not a bad idea
because I think capitalism whose only
stable ground we have is if there is
increasing levels of equity for more
people you know one of the things about
America that also is stunning to me is I
believe and there may be bigger experts
here never in human history have more
people being able to live in an
egalitarian society like the United
States which i think is one of those
other precious things you know people
talk about the blue-collar aristocracy
angus Deacon even has you know written
about it it's stunning I mean you know
how many people who were blue-collar
workers would have made something like
50,000 60,000 dollars which is what a
lot of what was the wage support that
they got in the u.s. to me those are
magical things that have happened in
capitalism and we have to somehow figure
out how that can be broad spread so at
least you know I I'm definitely a
capitalist
ah hi I run Microsoft but my father's
Marxist leanings at least get me to
think about what are the work shoes of
capitalism that we need to make sure we
preserve and not you know be blinded by
there aren't that many books by chief
executives that quote Terry Eagleton who
is a famous Marxist cultural commentator
but it's in his book number one yeah
this gentle oh yeah that's great there
gentlemen here and then the lady in the
blue top there yeah great and what's
your next project big killer project for
example you add office and windows
what's your next big killer project
well you're among friends is that if
they can tell us your next big launch
the thing that we're very excited about
it developments in three areas obviously
I'm not going to talk about my product
launch but you're all about sharing so
this is the new on we can test it there
are limits to it here's the thing I'm
very very excited about mixed reality I
think I'll be briefly touched on it but
this notion that what is your field of
view is a computing experience is I
think a real departure
it's the ultimate computing experience
in some sense we call it mixed reality
because we think of virtual reality
where you're fully immersed and
augmented reality is just a dial setting
versus two different platforms so we're
building devices we're building cloud
services for it we're well on our way on
that piece but lots to come the we
talked plenty about AI and what it can
do you know one of the projects that I'm
most excited about is Cortana in
particular as a digital assistant I send
mails and I'll say I'll follow up with
you tomorrow
it wakes up tomorrow and tells me have
you done that and it helps me you know
saves my day all the time you know one
of the other magical things that has
happened for us is Mission trance I mean
just basically language translation you
can be doing a PowerPoint presentation
and simultaneously translated into 60
plus languages and people can follow
along I mean the language barrier
and all of the things that happen in
communications but the thing that we
talked about even earlier this week for
the first time more publicly ah it's a
little ways out there is a quantum of
work you know for all this talk of great
progress we've made I'd like you know
the first supercomputer has had
something like 13 thousand transistors
the Xbox one X that's gonna come out in
October is gonna have seven billion
transistors so obviously we have a lot
of capacity yet let's talk about all the
computational problems that are not
solved
we can't even model an enzyme in natural
food production we don't have that
catalyst that can absorb the carbon in
the air
we can't design the new material that'll
be superconducting in high-temperature
for lossless power transmission these
are all computational problems and if
you try to solve it using a classical
computer it'll take as much time as if
there has been between Big Bang to now
so we need a new approach and
interestingly enough quantum mechanics
does give us at least a theory and we
are well on way a well on our way to
bring the math the physics and the
computer science because all the
computer science at least I learned is
just redundant for a quantum computer
and so we've got to put a complete new
system together so these are all
ambitious projects that we are excited
about and and we'll keep talking about
it in the years to come
great okay yeah that's not a number one
and then the lady at the back just at
the back of this block thanks yeah hi
there thank you and it's been really
inspirational and encouraging to hear
some of the things you've been talking
about particularly as a fellow CEO
working in a different sector so I lead
a company in financial services trying
to rebuild trust in the financial sector
but really through working out how we
can work with technology and education
to bring financial security to the
masses and I think there are so many
parallels I draw from the things we've
talked about but I don't see technology
companies like yourselves embracing this
challenge working with us in financial
services to try and bring this kind of
change around these kinds of
inequalities around basic
financial education and security I'd
love your thoughts on that I mean I
think the first thing that you talked
about it's an issue that in fact I write
a bit about which is trust and how are
we as a technology company going to earn
the trust of users of digital technology
and that's a very multi constituent
piece and that's where I think we have
to do some of the best work ourselves as
technology providers but also we need a
policy framework that allows us to do
that but do your very specific question
this is the place where at least in our
context at Microsoft our entire business
model and our entire focus is how can we
take digital technology and apply it in
healthcare in financial services in any
other sector of the economy so that they
can drive the dividends to all of their
constituents right that to me I mean
when I think about the cloud and what it
can mean it's an ingredient you know for
you to be able to reduce your
transactional costs and then I look at
even all of the blockchain applications
that are being written it's all
fundamentally so that the transactional
cost can come down and they can be more
trust and then whatever surplus gets
created gets actually split and you know
across all the constituents so my job at
least as I think of it is to really
bring that force of commoditization to
industry after industry
and we would definitely love to partner
up and we are in fact even right here in
the UK whether it's in financial
services or others and we do that not
only through technology but we have a
massive you know social responsibility
and philanthropies piece to it too as
well and working with the government's
in partnership so it will be something
we should follow up in stock cards as a
lady just at the back there at this
block and then we'll come to that end
and then that's that side there yeah
yeah
good evening so tell I'm really enjoying
this interview you've helped settle a
long-standing disagreement between my
husband and I because he said nonviolent
communicate
we'll never go mainstream and you
mentioning it in some of your interviews
has made go up into the Amazon
bestseller list so thank you I'm
wondering when I hear words like empathy
and vulnerability in business I'm really
excited but I'm wondering if you had any
pushback and what's your anything you
have to say about NECN business I mean
again I was introduced in fact one of
the things that I've realized as part of
writing this book and definitely doing
these talks is the real reader in the
house is my wife and you know she's the
one who introduced me to Carole to act
and she's the one who really introduced
me to even NDC I have not tried to
approach anything inside Microsoft as
some new dogma that I'm trying to
propagate if anything even the growth
mindset I you know I did that's one of
the reasons why I'm afraid of it quite
frankly because I think the one way for
cultural change to get stymied is when
it's viewed as okay it's sort of one
person's agenda versus I want to do this
because it helps me and the reason why
if there is any success of this growth
mindset or even NVC inside the company
is because people are drawing upon it
because it gives them or it inspires
them and they can be a better partner a
better parent a better colleague a
better leader and in fact harmonizes
what is their life and work that I think
is the power of these techniques or
books or mindsets or whatever you want
to call it at least that's my point of
view so I mean I'd push back and push
back within the business and in and and
I as I said like I'm not even sort of
saying let me push it on you ah so to
some degree take it if it appeals to you
if it doesn't it doesn't matter at least
that's what we are trying to do which is
let's give it a lot of breathing space
the other thing I've realized is most
people interpret things differently
it's because we're all shaped by our
life's experiences we're all in
different stages of life's experiences
me I myself was very different as my
book proves at 25 versus 50 and how I
would have reacted to someone telling me
about NBC at 25 would have been pretty
different then I'm sure it is now as
again you know it's true and so that's
how I would approach him number three
there yeah yeah hi there thank you for
an excellent talk I wanted to ask on
FinTech it's also a large part of the
digital revolution we're seeing big
companies and to the space you know
Apple and Google already entering the
payment space what a Microsoft planning
and what are your visions or views
around how FinTech and impact and help
the world it's really too even I think a
little bit of a previous question but
overall we're very clear about the what
role we want to play in the various
industry whether it's fin tack or even
health tack or any of the new areas
where essentially their digital products
in these different sectors we want to be
a platform we do not want to directly
participate in these markets but we want
to work with startups we want to work
with established players and take
whatever the AI component the cloud
component the device components and
commoditized it that to me is how we
construct our business model because I
think going back to trust what is going
to be a real currency for digital
companies like ours is going to be trust
in business model more so than anything
else if you say one day that you know
yeah you should use my cloud but you
ain't know by the way I have a car
company and I have a drug company and a
fin tech company on the side no fin tech
company no drug company no car companies
want to work with you so you've got to
be very principled about what businesses
you're in how the business model but
stability because we're cons now we're
not just an office system you're really
built into the cost of goods of the
product
and so as a supplier you need to make
sure that you have real stability your
business model and that's at least what
I'm focused on number two it's quite a
few run there so yeah yes how do you
think of bringing in India has
influenced and shaped your views and
empathy and running Microsoft you know
I'm a product of you know having grown
up in India and then essentially or my
higher education and professional
experiences all Americans so I don't
know how to delineate the two and the
blend between the two quite frankly it's
one of the things that I even tried to
say well what what's American about me
or what is Indian about me I am
obviously an American of Indian origin
but if anything I think it's my parents
and their views and in particular my
mother as I now recognize it the way she
instilled in me perhaps that calmness
right which is you know I sometimes
think it's so important for us to be
able to do our very best given an
opportunity in the moment as someone
described this to me you can't wait for
your next job to do your best work and a
little bit of that I think is my mom's
influence which in in an interesting way
all of what might say my dad gave me in
terms of intellectual curiosity was
helpful but what I think my mom taught
me is perhaps the more enduring lesson
that I find has definitely shaped Who I
am but so yeah yes so it's fascinating
till you talk about your mother
Sanskrit professor your name sati or in
Sanskrit its truth or truthfulness a
problem that a lot of leaders CEOs say
they they suffer from is the further up
the food chain you get the less truth
you hear how do you approach that
problem in Microsoft
no one's honest to you yeah there's
leave down here yeah it is I mean I
think all loves
structures and how information flows in
structures is one of the harder
challenges but frankly one of the things
we've gone to work and this is an area
where we have a lot to do because of the
tools we create and the systems we
create one of the ways I at least like
to push to keep in touch every morning I
get up and the first thing I see is the
email notification on from Yammer which
is where we have the water cooler
conversation at Microsoft all the
hundred thousand people are buzzing
about whatever is top of mind and we
have and they ask me all the questions
they need to or their community are
talking about their issue of the day and
I got to be in touch with it so that's
it's an amazing tool for me to be in
touch with what people are thinking as
opposed to walking into office not
knowing what's top of mind but it
doesn't end there one of the other
things that we do a lot of is these
townhall type of meetings and we use our
technology they're one of the most
intimidating things is while I am
talking first of all we broadcasted over
Skype and it's translated into any
language and people are able to react to
it with emojis ah and luckily enough I
don't see it in real-time but that's
behind me but one of the things that we
do is we analyze all of the emojis after
and they're all anonymous so therefore
if there are lots of thumbs down on
whatever I said that's a signal that's
one way information flows so we use a
lot of our technology to some degree to
keep that flow of information and being
touch and as you said the real currency
perhaps nowadays is how does you know
truth prevail and whether it's about how
you lead organizations or in our society
or anywhere and I think it's an
important issue digital tools can help
there are also unintended consequences
as we know you've got to tackle them all
lady here I just wanted to ask a
question as a parent and you mentioned
your mother and father what advice can
we give youngsters about the digital
world and the benefits it brings but
also some of the very negative
connotations and things that happen
online for young people you know I mean
I'll give you the very practical work
that at least you and I are doing with
our children as they're growing up and
it's to one have real dialog around both
the power of the technology and the
empowerment but as well as all of the
challenges of it in fact their own
responsibility for example you know
let's take cybersecurity one of the
things I think is so important for
everyone to know whether you're a senior
citizen or a young child is your
responsibility to protect yourself week
as technology providers clearly are the
first responders and we have tremendous
amount to do but there is also such a
thing as being educated on what it means
to secure yourself it's like crossing
the road how do you teach a child on how
to you know you know do that safely I
think a little bit of that and spending
the time talking through it is very
helpful then the same thing you know in
my house at least there's always a
negotiation that happens all the time on
screen time and luckily enough there are
tools vu I mean I you know obviously use
Microsoft account and you know we have
we have transparency I mean I see what
they're seeing they know that and that's
a great way of at least us being able to
have to be on screen so I'm sorry what
is your view on screens aren't you have
cutoff moments oh yes we do in our case
at least it is at least an hour or so
before going to bed is when we cut off
screen time and then also I think it's
what do you do with the time you have on
the screen is also the next level
because I think it's easy to get
distracted one of the other things you
can forget my children
I need those tools and I use those too
because it's easy to sort of be
undisciplined by just either being on
the email threads but you need to do
real work which might require either
thinking or writing these are I think
important skills even in digital world
even if you're writing digitally so have
and in one of the things that we do is
we track how you're spending your time
this is analytics for you it's not about
it's like you know going to the gym and
having data on you whether you exercised
or not time if it's your scarce
commodity we should treat it like your
health yeah yeah at the back yeah thank
you for sharing the story about your son
I found it very moving I my husband and
I just have had a new baby and I've
returned back to work so you obviously
have commitments at home and have
commitments to Microsoft and I wondered
if you had any tips on balancing in and
how you manage both I don't know if I
have any sort of tips except for what I
would need tried to do because it's such
a hard thing I mean this work-life
balance as some folks would describe it
it's just a real challenge and I've
struggled with it both my wife and I in
fact in some sense it was because of our
son's condition my wife had to even make
the hard trade-off of not going back
into the workforce
the one thing that oh I I think of now
is more the harmony versus the balance
because it's impossible for me to say
this is an equation that somehow has to
be balanced in all time so I'm at least
trying to develop in me more discipline
on in the moments I'm there
am I really there and this again is a
bit of a screen time type of question
there's lots of times I'm there and yet
I'm on my phone or I'm on my computer
and that's you know you're physically
there but you're really not
and so to me being disciplined about
doing those few things with your
children or with with my wife that are
more meditative in the sense that you're
in the moment I think are super
important and it requires a lot of
discipline and it's very hard at least
but that's at least what I'm pushing
myself to do I carry just about up to
time so the last two questions will take
together there's a gentleman or a woman
out there it was a woman actually but
you can even a Nichkhun are you okay as
good work-life balance there okay fine
yeah hopefully it's better yeah you
speaking for your the person next to you
yeah good so thank you the question is
coming back to AI and you've mentioned
about cyber security as well you know
talking about the control problem where
we have super intelligent AI that might
be released how confident I you in in
terms of cyber security when you know
cyber security nowadays as you know
99.9% is a good metric of screening for
for threats so how how how confident are
you in developing that when in the
future you know 99 percent might not be
good enough one last question here
that'll be it yeah one last question
yeah
very quick on thank you for your talk oh
sorry yeah sorry yeah her yeah sorry
sorry
yeah so how do you think about China and
what's happening there because obviously
the focus has been the Silicon Valley
but a lot of work is going on in China
for in terms of technology and
development and do you have any thoughts
is it is it a threat it's an opportunity
and how do you deal with China that's a
great question so let me just take the
things quickly
um the control problem clearly is a one
of the big challenges as AGI happens and
my only point is let us not abdicate our
ability to control the control problem
if that makes any sense in other words
there is a lot of research that needs to
be done today on the control problem
what are four examples these are runaway
optimization challenges that's why I
kind of talk about what how do you make
compute
or these algorithms intelligible and
test them what is the test harness for
an agent that is independent you know
can you use some mechanism like these
adversarial networks to in fact test
even the the agent so I think that
there's a lot of research that a lot of
people at Microsoft and elsewhere and
this is another place where the
partnership of AI should be very helpful
let's even take techniques we develop
around this like good tooling we had in
computer science or insecurities like
threat modeling put it into the public
domain so that we can in fact all get
better so that's how I view that China
up you know one of the things we talked
a lot about is mostly Silicon Valley
companies and and so on but you're
clearly what the Chinese companies are
doing in technology and in fact I would
say across industries it's pretty
phenomenal and I think the dialogue
between the United States the United
Kingdom the rest of the European Union
and China is all going to be important
we can't think of this as let's the
Western countries talk and figure this
out and China is going to be something
that we'll deal with later if anything
even take AI development whatever I just
said about the control problem around AI
if people from China have to be full
participants in that dialogue and that
like needs to be my what I will advocate
every opportunity I get and that's what
my hope would be that we are G Satya
thank you so much time is sadly against
us 90 minutes of fascinating thoughts
from you thank you to you the audience
to some fantastic questions thank you to
intelligence squared but in the main
thank you to Satya his book is on sale
in the foyer I recommend you go and buy
it
you